as usual i'm going to be discussing
scenes in detail we'll be going over
spoilers especially since the main
conflict this episode is inherently
spoilery so take that at your own will
opening with rainier doing some
real-life tinder swiping this is one
scene that i wish was a bit longer and
showed us more lords from around the
world of westeros so far that's one
aspect the show is doing expertly
because the world feels like it's lived
in and is vibrant there are so many
houses within this world and it's shown
from the sheer amount of characters on
display in just these few episodes
unlike the later seasons of game of
thrones where it feels like the world is
empty and the councils at the end were
just made up of friends we made along
the way but here in house of the dragon
putting emphasis on any minor house
further fleshes out the world
significantly and gives it a lot of
depth like i didn't know who the
blackwoods were but this kid's actions
were badass as hell and it's very sad
that rainer rejected him like this man
is a chad and you can't ignore him
although i think they cut to the next
scene right before he was about to throw
up i also love the fact that we don't
see the initial stab and we are left to
assume that the kid probably died only
to reveal that he surprisingly rolled
the bully that and this scene
re-establishes the awkward conflict of
marrying someone drastically out of your
age bracket which is further explored in
the rest of the episode so overall a
very effective introductory scene then
already for this episode due to its
nature we're getting into spoilers since
renier is getting the hots for damon
targaryen
it really goes to show that ernie is
obsessed with him since he literally die
bombs her boat like a douchebag and she
is still getting googly eyes for him and
before talking about their complicated
dynamic the throne room scene where
damon essentially flaunts around as a
badass and tries to cement himself as a
noble hero was pretty cathartic i love
how the creators wrote the scene where
there's a ton of tension and they draw
this out with viserys being deadpan and
slowly approaching daemon you really
don't know where the direction of the
scene is going and it's pretty
surprising that damon had no ill intent
on the surface at least also in this
scene i love the mirroring that they're
doing between otto hightower and
littlefinger him scouring on the side of
the court and staring down people
reminds me heavily of littlefinger and
winterfell which on the subject of otto
hightower rhysafon does so much with so
little dialogue if you think about it
almost all of it is just exposition and
relaying information but yet he's one of
the most engaging characters in the show
so far i think this is due to the fact
of rhysaphon's amazing delivery of every
line that feels meticulously planned and
crafted even him saying a simple line
like your grace has different variations
that's infused with different
connotations what must i say it your
praise your grace your grace your grace
i'm sorry your grace that's hardly how i
viewed it your grace
what you wanted me your great your craze
otto hightower also takes a character
beat between almost every line of
dialogue to thoroughly show us what he's
feeling the scene in which he's relaying
the information of her nearest night out
with damon shows so much hesitation
between each line of dialogue it's
engrossing to see so much conflict with
anim just telling the king information
because otto doesn't know if he should
do the right thing and notify the king
thus angering him or sweep this under
the rug you can even draw from the scene
that otto wanted to tell viserys this
information and is putting on a show of
hesitation but i think the brief shot
before this scene tells the opposite of
this it looks like he's preparing to do
a heinous act like he's going to regret
because otto was a very smart man and i
don't think he'd want to intentionally
lie to the king to gain further value
but instead i think he genuinely is
trying to do a good job being hand so he
can mutually gain more power in the
process so it's kind of sad to see him
try his best and tell viserys the hard
truths just for him to lose his position
as hand and you never know maybe i'm
reading it the wrong way and otto's
doing some five head littlefinger mind
games that's just the beauty of these
scenes because they're so complex that
you can just interpret them in a
multitude of different ways it's also
really good to see viserys getting a
scene where he isn't making any grave
errors it gives his character more of a
moment to shine since he hasn't had a
lot of victories but even this action
could bring about consequences
i just hope that lionel strong ends up
becoming the hand because that's a loyal
guy that i want to see in the spotlight
moving on we have the social gathering
outside within the red keep and there's
two moments in particular that struck me
the first one being that i'm loving that
viserys is becoming more of an alcoholic
he's really channeling his inner bobby b
and him laughing at his wife was
hilarious and i like the fact that the
writers are trying to rekindle the
relationship between alison and rhaenyra
them relating over the disgusting and
absurd fact of a bunch of male lords in
the realm fiending over them was pretty
wholesome then the scene even manages to
cut deeper when rainier says that she
doesn't want to be a prisoner in a
castle forced to have children since
that's essentially what's happening to
allison's their relationship is just so
tragic so far because they are genuinely
friends deep down but because of their
positions and statuses they're going to
be pitted against each other so it's
nice to get a small taste of them liking
each other's company before the knives
come out
within the scene we also have renier and
damon getting along and so far their
chemistry together is so infectious i
think the contrast of vernier kind of
being unimpressed or not very enthused
by most people's company to them being
with daemon where she's always happy
around him further emphasizes how much
she really likes him and if anyone
thinks their relationship so far is
weird just remember that the targaryens
are very incestuous so honestly that
doesn't bother me at all and this is a
fantasy at the end of the day as long as
they seem like they actually like each
other then the potential romance between
them is a-okay which leads into their
little adventure at night this scene
actually did a lot that i loved firstly
in just one minute of vernier and damon
walking down the street in king's
landing the portrayal of the city feels
so much more real and vibrant than
anything that was shown in the last few
seasons of game of thrones because in
game of thrones king's landing became
extremely shallow and lost all of its
character and just became a mindless
crowd who ironically supported cersei
despite her killing thousands of
innocents
lost was all the grimy characteristics
in the rough edges of the population
however in house of the dragon the
craters show copious amounts of details
and even the placing was a welcomed
edition initially in game of thrones i
didn't really care much for the play
scenes in season 6 because it felt more
like filler but that isn't the case for
this scene because the play shows the
perspective the common people have about
rainier becoming queen right in front of
her it's a lot more relevant than just
recapping the events of the show thus
far in a comedic way but instead
twisting that knife of conflict of
succession into the heart of rhaenyra
then this leads into damon and renera
getting a little frisky which to me the
scene was a little contrived i know
ranira had a bit to drink despite it not
really being clear how drunk she was
which she didn't seem that drunk but she
should be smarter than wanting to have
sex with damon in public because this
event sets forth a lot of major conflict
and any whiff of it not coming across as
natural and was forced to happen by the
writers will feel like it invalidates
the coming scenes i can see why she made
these mistakes because of her alcohol
consumption but i feel like they should
have made that fact more clear that she
was actually under the influence and
wasn't herself because even the scene
after this where she has sex with her
kirsten cole which ay my guy she seems
more sexually frustrated and teased
which drove her to wanting to do that
instead of the alcohol or it's really
just a combination of both
one aspect about the scene though that i
really liked was the contrast between
alison spending her night with visceras
and rainer and damon having a night out
showing love and happiness and then the
opposite side of the coin where it's
more of an obligation and duty that's
becoming taxing there's an overall smart
way to showcase these two scenes
together that perfectly utilizes
parallel editing that and allison in
these scenes is doing a magnificent job
all these young actors so far are really
surprising me like these are genuinely
some outstanding performances
next we have daemon and viserys's
confrontation the blocking of the scene
where daemon is just on the ground as
viserys is looming over him is great it
immediately shows the power dynamic and
viserys is actually being menacing for
once which this episode is showing him
as being more fierce which is nice to
see since he's normally pretty soft in
the scene though it's revealed that
damon was actually making a play for the
throne and lies that he had sex with
renera it turns an already complex
situation and evolves into a surprising
revelation that damon was just
manipulating rainer this whole time his
plan of trying to soil raniera to
devalue her for marriage isn't very
smart because viserys can easily just
deny it and outcast damon but this whole
scenario is still juicy nonetheless
hopefully though this acts as more of a
character building moment for rhaenyra
and her being more resilient to being
manipulated in the future damon's
revelation also offers more context
within the rest of the episode and is
probably why damon was on such good
behavior with his brother earlier i
always love scenes that change the way
you view the prior ones and make you
want to go back and watch them then the
ending of the scene is golden where
daemon after failing just goes to sleep
on the floor because he's hung over i
love that man so much for the final
scene i want to talk about we have
rainer and versailis talk about
potential things that happen in the bump
of the night i like how each episode so
far has a climactic confrontation of
sorts between rainier and viserys this
time though viserys is kind of on his
hot streak of being menacing and he even
kind of scares and unsettles ronira at
the start of the scene he opens the
dialogue with responsibilities that
renewer has inherited and he again
references a song of ice and fire and
talks about the prince who was promised
which going back to the first episode i
don't think they should keep reminding
the audience of the underwhelming end of
game of thrones like ah yes the prince
who was promised is so important that
david and dan completely dropped that
notion all together and just allowed
arya to kill the night king because they
wanted to subvert expectations so the
creators putting the emphasis on this in
house of the dragon is a little
distracting to say the least but the
rest of the scene is obviously great
anything between viserys and or nira is
always stellar and all the conflict they
treach through together is very engaging
overall episode 4 was really good and
initially after finishing it i wasn't
that crazy about the episode but after
thinking about it more it really grew on
me
massive thanks to the writers for being
skilled enough to write dramatic
material that doesn't overly rely on
spectacle thank you for watching and let
me know what you thought about episode 4
of house of the dragon